Johnson Presidential Library in Austin
Texas they discuss their insider account
of the LBJ presidency this is 50 minutes
[Applause]
welcome friends it's so good to see you
on this rainy night historians of the
Johnson presidency have long yearned for
access to the papers of the man who
functioned as President Johnson's chief
of staff and later served in his cabinet
as Postmaster General W Marvin Watson
Watson was arguably closer to President
Johnson for a longer period of time than
any other assistant and was asked to
give the eulogy at the president's
funeral in Washington of Marvin Watson
President Johnson said Marvin is as wise
as my father as gentle as my mother as
loyal and dedicated and as close to my
side as Lady Bird so you can see why
historians have been interested in his
story known as the mystery man of the
White House Watson gave his papers
[Music]
nice timing there since I'm about to say
that Watson gave his papers 19 file
cabinets and 45 boxes to the LBJ library
where they have remained sealed at his
request until now - only one man have
they been accessible his co-author and
fellow presidential assistant Sherwin
Markman as a young man Markman was the
Iowa chairman for Adlai Stevenson's
campaigns for president and in 1964 was
instrumental and working out that
successful solution to the Mississippi
freedom Democratic Party's bid to be
seated at the Democratic National
Convention in 1965 he came to Washington
where he worked at the State Department
and then a special assistant to
President Johnson later he practiced law
in Washington in addition to Co editing
a collection of essays Martin is the
author of a novel called the election
and he's currently writing another we
asked mr. Martin to kick off the program
by talking about how this
much-anticipated story actually became a
book and to introduce his longtime
friend and collaborator Marvin Watson
ladies and gentlemen please help me
welcome
Sherwin Markman and Marvin Watson
[Applause]
Thank You Betty Sue mrs. Johnson and
friends it's such a great honor for us
to be here George Christian
we all remember so well and love so much
was press secretary said that all of us
have a story all of us have multiple
stories about President Johnson nobody
who worked with him lacks those and I
could stay here it stand here and give a
lot of them but this is Marvin's night
and he is the champion of this show and
I want to introduce him in just a moment
he was my protector when the president
sometimes got angry at me sometimes
happened he also stood between me and
the president at times when I might have
fouled up and he also made sure that the
president might be made aware of
anything I might do right I was my wife
Peggy who was here and I after I quit
practicing law went off sailing and the
two of us actually lived on a sailboat
for seven years the two of us across the
North Atlantic by ourselves and then our
sailing career ended in about 2000 and
my son Allah who was a professor of
history at East Central University
suggested that we put together an
anthology of essays by people who are
still around who knew President Johnson
best and so we embarked on that project
and we actually we got essays from Lucy
Johnson and from Joe Califano and Jack
miletti Harry Middleton and Jim Cross
and we also very much wanted a an essay
from Marvin Watson so one afternoon we
were sitting in Marvin's den with Peggy
was there and my son-in-law and was
there and we asked Marvin for an essay
and he said no I have a better idea a
more important idea said my family who's
been trying to get me to tell my story
for all these years
and this was a in January of 2000 and I
have been thinking about it and I've
decided that the person who should write
that book is you and I said oh no Marvin
I'm no way am I going to do that and
then Peggy jumped in and said now that
you're off the sailboat and we're living
in Florida you shouldn't let your brains
just fry up in the Florida Sun that was
before all the Hurricanes hit us of
course so I accepted and thus embarked
on a project that lasted almost four
years I realized very quickly that this
was going to be a very very special
opera
as Betty Sue mentioned everybody who
knew Marvin and the loved him but the
public had never been told his story he
had been called the mystery man of the
White House his files which took up all
this space and up here at the library
had never been looked at by anyone and
he has never he had never spoken to
anyone so this was I thought a marvelous
opportunity to to to become aware of all
these facts and to participate in
letting the public know what all these
facts were so I came to the library
first and I must say I received just the
greatest cooperation from Harry
Middleton who was then the director from
Tina Houston from Linda selkie from all
the people who work here it was just a
tremendous experience and together with
my unpaid assistant
Peggy Markman who stayed in the public
reading room for weeks at a time we
finally got through all of Marvins
papers and after that I spent weeks and
weeks of time four full days of time
interviewing Marvin and slowly this book
came together and now it's out it was
just released and I think it is a book
that should be of some interest and some
important interests not only to the
public at large but to historians there
is much in this book that is new and
different and I'm not going to go
through all anything but one story which
I consider of great historical
significance because it clears up a lot
of misunderstanding about President
Johnson and it demonstrates in the most
vivid of ways the openness of President
Johnson's mind and it also changes what
people think of as what really happened
and it involves President Johnson and
his view toward the dissenters against
the Vietnam War people know that there
was at that time the Undersecretary of
State George ball they also know that
George ball in the meetings of the
cabinet and of the wise men and all of
the other times when the war was being
considered and argued he was the great
dissenter and what people think is that
his dissent was barely tolerated by
President Johnson but the true facts has
revealed in this book and as Marvin
Watson knows are these one day in the
Cabinet Room a heavy discussion was
going on regarding the Vietnam War and
those sitting in the Cabinet Room could
hear out on Pennsylvania Avenue the
voices of all those kids at that time
who were marching in dissent of the war
and the president sort of stopped the
proceedings and said you know they
though there are so many people out
there who are dissenting and there was a
sense are going on around the country
but none of them have a voice in this
room secretary Rusk said but they're
only kids and the president replied no
that may be true but they should have a
voice in here and that sort of ended the
discussion for the time being when the
meeting ended the president summoned
George ball who had been a perfectly
willing supporter of the war into the
Oval Office and with Marvin present this
conversation occurred the president said
George you're a terrific lawyer you're
probably one of the best lawyers in this
room George said Thank You mr. president
he said George I want you to do one job
for me and one job only from here on out
from now on
every time we are meeting
whether it be in the cabinet room or
with the Secretary of Defense or with
whomever however private I want you to
pose the best possible argument that can
be articulated in dissent of the war and
nobody is to know that I asked you to do
that and I will never stop you and so
from that moment on at every single
meeting George ball was the voice of
dissent it disturbed some of the other
people who were in the inner circles of
the administration but the president
never stopped him but what nobody knew
until Marvin Rio Beale in this book is
that what George ball was doing was that
was that was at the specific direction
of President Johnson to me that
demonstrates the breadth of the
president it shows that he was willing
to and anxious to hear other points of
view as he himself said to George ball
when people are unanimous I wonder
whether they are right there was that
and many other things in this book that
Marvin reveals that I would suggest and
that others read there's one other thing
that I want to cover and that is the
title of the book chief of staff as
everybody who worked for President
Johnson knows there was nobody who had
that formal designation everybody who
was at the top echelons of the present
staff bore the title of special
assistant Marvin had worked for
President Johnson I think since 1948 and
as he worked for him beginning in those
years he became closer and closer with
the President and with the president's
family and it wasn't very soon very long
after he started to work that the
president
asked him to come on board as a member
of his staff and Marvin refused and
continued to refuse and the president's
insisted is everyone who knew Lyndon
Johnson no new nose became greater and
greater and more and more difficult to
resist and then came the tragedy of
Walder Jenkins in the fall of 1964 and
Walter Jenkins had to resign and then
the pressure became almost unbearable
and then came January of 1965 and Marvin
knew that he would no longer be able to
or not for not much longer be able to
resist the import tunings of the
President to come on board and so he
didn't know exactly how to handle it and
at that moment he went to consult his
very close friend and the close friend
of the president the then Texas governor
of Texas John Connally and I want to
read from you to you just a few short
paragraphs from the book which will
explain how the title of this book chief
of staff came about Marvin had governor
Cod Lee were meeting down here in Texas
governor Connally said you know you
won't be able to refuse him again Marvin
said I realized that and said so they
discussed the options and they decided
that Marvin would not work for the
President as as anything less than his
chief of staff the title doesn't mean a
thing
governor Connally said what counts is
that you will be his chief of staff
because your actual duties and
responsibilities were all add up to that
Governor Connally and Marvin insisted
that Marvin should insist on some
symbols of authority that nobody else
could duplicate such as having the
president agree that Marvin could attend
any meeting that they may have without
exception and without prior
authorization and that he was that
Marvin could express his opinion on any
subject at any time up until the time
the president
made up his mind those and other symbols
of authority were those that Governor
Connally said that Marvin should ask and
Marvin then when he was then asked by
the president one that one final time to
serve said yes I'm willing to come
aboard sir but I want us to agree on a
few things and he presented those things
to the president and the president
agreed and said you know only you and I
will understand that you will operate as
my chief of staff and then the president
added I also know that neither one of us
will ever regret that decision and
neither one of them did and so Marvin
came on board on February 1 1965
Marvin is a member of the greatest
generation that Tom Brokaw called he
served in the marine corps on Iwo Jima
and Okinawa during World War two then to
Johnson used to call him my tough marine
but his Betty Sue said he was the man
who Lyndon Johnson considered as loyal
and dedicated as anyone he knew except
for Lady Bird and so it gives me the
greatest pleasure and honor to present
you my former colleague and my dear
friend Marvin Watson
[Applause]
he's a pretty good lawyer also you know
we're married and I now live there is
such an appreciation for the vision of
the president and miss Johnson the
vision they had for the natural
resources of this nation and its
preservation last month there was an
article in our local paper a long and
winding trail and he explains about the
Snake River in the various places out in
the West that we consider beautiful and
this is what the article said President
Lyndon Johnson walked rapidly into the
Rose Garden at the White House quickly
greeting some of those gathered there
took the podium and made his formal
remarks then he sat down at a small desk
next to the lectern chatting over his
shoulder with his congressional allies
gather around him LBJ reached out his
texas-sized hand gather a fistful of
pins from her right and begin to sign
the documents before him I'm still
getting letters about that time you went
to the trip you took with my wife he
said to secretary Udall who stood behind
him everyone liest I didn't think the
President did it that day September the
8th 1964 the Monument Wilderness Act
became law what did that mean what was
different about that what was the vision
that Johnson's had
it was the first statutory protection of
natural resources in this mission 40
years ago last month it provided an
overlying protection to federal lands
that can only be altered by Congress
itself that was an important step and
one that came about easily but this
followed the genius of legislative
affairs of this nation London Johnson
but this territory that you set up in
the National Forest miss Johnson and the
president Mary and I see it every day
and we enjoyed and there's nothing on it
but wilderness and and the wild animals
and the visitors and there's some four
million of those it comes to the town of
Jackson Wyoming Jackson Hole Wyoming
every year to see the natural beauty
they can never be disturbed unless
Congress itself changes it terrowin
Markman I thank you for your kind
invitation he knew I had the last word
you had no idea what I'd say about you
so you did the very best you could and I
thank you and it was well I will not
speak any evil of you this night dr.
flowers miss Johnson Glinda Rob
Peggy Markman and those that helped
locate the files and records needing and
write needed in writing the chief of
staff Marion I always enjoy Austin so
very much as you would expect because
it's here that our son Winston Lee and
his wife Katherine in our first
grandchild Meredith Leah
but tonight Harry Middleton I want a
public to say that I thank you very much
for you assisted and you led of the
President and Miss Johnson and
established in this place we enjoy so
much
but before I start may I request any and
all people that ever served on president
and miss Johnson staff to please stand
and let us know you're here
[Applause]
[Music]
well in the book you if those of you
that care to invest almost $30 and I
wish if you would in the book if you
read it I say that this was the best
White House style there ever was I think
the president believed that I believe
that and the more I read about the
future the staff since then I know it
was true since then that you were and
you are the best and we thank you since
arriving Mary and I this evening this
day have helped such a strong fellowship
with each of you
I accept that fellowship as individuals
that share something in common that
common feeling is the knowledge we're
here to discuss a life of service that
was given by lyndon b johnson who lived
is sixty-four years of life with purpose
and may i remind you with great great
vigor we gather his friends that knew
him our knew of him we accept that he
loved all god had made and gave himself
to build improve and challenge each and
all of that it's so much fun to be here
at this beautiful prestigious and
imposing facility the president and miss
Johnson spent so much time dreaming and
planning how to preserve and and present
the records of their work in addition
and equally important was their planning
and financing of a school that would
attract students worldwide I hope to be
taught and trained for public works and
the leadership required
personally I believe they did a great
and successful work Thank You miss
Johnson
[Applause]
[Music]
wherever I visit wherever I communicate
I have so often been reminded of the
lives that Johnson's have known an
influence this week I received such a
letter our core part of it I have many
memories of times with President Johnson
both in Washington at the ranch
I love the whole Johnson family we hear
from Lady Bird on the phone as she talks
to Linda what marvelous women they are
signed Billy Graham MS Johnson yesterday
when I travel down 35 with my wife
coming south as fast as I could I was
glad it was no high we were trolling
around we past exit 302 just north of
temple I look to the east which was to
my left and there was this several acres
surrounded by 6 or 8 foot fence solid of
course it was a wrecking yard behind him
but in the front they had built a
two-story structure and this structure I
assume Hamill's apartments for the
employees may be some security people
certainly the place for for customers to
come but I couldn't help to be kind but
to think and to be thankful that you had
such a vision that our highways needed
to protect it and they needed to be
pretty
instead of cluttered again I want to
thank you for me miss Johnson for that
vision that you had you know this and
our site there was never that was her
husband that that understood the
importance of his wife more than lyndon
b johnson he loved you and it showed
in addition I watched when he sought
your advice your counsel and the ideas
of Lady Bird Johnson and Karnak Texas he
not only wanted her approval he worked
and schemed how to enjoy her smile and
her nod which always said when he got it
go ahead I agree I said it because he
didn't know what you didn't believe me
yes miss Johnson he was proud of you
work in beautifying America the work in
the national parks and your visits to
the various sections of America and your
reports and your suggestions however you
should know these late years for those
of us that were with him we so dreaded
every time you departed the White House
his attitude changed his he smiled
seldom he worked to or past midnight
then he had dinner and every once in a
while we had dinner with him man
with that your present he was obviously
lonesome and saying you truly were his
strength your abilities your talents he
recognized and oh ha he respected he
knew you had willingly and gladly given
moral and spiritual instruction with
proper training in love to his and your
two daughters he recognized your gentle
and quite spirit as the foundation of
his family
and now President Johnson had had I
won't call it a weakness he had a trait
that he seldom bossed approval and
appreciation to to a person for a job
well done not face to face instead he
would at an introduction or a special
time maybe even at a national press
conference tailed the third person how
great he really thought they were
so the deserving one hurt him when all
the other world heard it maybe as an
example at a presidential news
conference he said I think I would have
made my parents happier if at 16 or 18
or 20 I had conducted myself to the same
high standards of morals as my
daughter's apply to themselves now and
he said that the national press
conference I'm sure that miss Linda and
Lucy were in glad to get their message
from their father in such a way his
thank-yous were very sincere and yet we
must know that that he delivered those
as most any husband or father and boss
would do in his age group if he was from
the hill country because the they had
been taught as I was in East Texas that
if you were a man no emotions were to
show they were to be hidden from all the
public and if possible for many of your
family members however things changed up
there however the president often in
news conferences and speeches would
deliver his personal things his ideas
his dreams and commitments such as he
said in another Washington DC press
conference in July 64 well I am against
sin and I'm against lawlessness and I'm
very much opposed to violence at least
think we have to put a stop to it
later that same year in Denver Colorado
and if I am your president I'm not going
to preach the golden rules I'm sorry I'm
only going to preach the golden rule
throughout the world and throughout this
land do unto others who do have them do
unto you and I'm going to practice it
then on November election time prior to
the election he told him Austin crowd it
was here as a bar
as a barefoot boy around my daddy's desk
in that Great Hall of the House of
Representatives where he served for six
years and where my grand grandfather
served ahead of him that I first learned
that government is not an enemy of the
people
and on February 65 after the election he
said in Washington
what of the system will permit the son
of a tenant farmer who was born in a
three-room house 56 years ago to become
president of his land he was delivering
his messages for every day the President
Johnson was the day of opportunity and
you must miss it and you better be a
part of it if you go to be on the team
he wants to ask a group to join him in
Oklahoma City he said to them so let's
go home tonight and let's don't feel
sorry and weep on our pillow let's say
our prayers and thank our good Lord
Almighty that we're as lucky as we are
and that we enjoy the blessings that are
ours some have reviewed my book and say
I've tried to make him a Christian no I
can assure you he made that decision
before I was ever on the payroll how
pleased and happy I am that he was his
decision some people say why you write
in this book for those of you they're
not were not in the White House I had a
job to meet with every possible
presidential appointee and give him my
suggestions and recommendations along
with meeting I was to deliver a message
of two parts one you agree your retire
no later than 70 so young people can
come in and have an opportunity first
second thing you agree you will never
write a book on Lyndon Baines Johnson
that's what I did I would tell you of
all of those people are counseled in
such a way very few books have been
written but no one retired its end
either at first in my case my family did
suggest I write a book and second I had
another purpose and it's my attempt to
correct what we read and hear about the
36th President Lyndon Baines Johnson
such as why he did not run for
reelection some said he could not have
one other say oh no one that was Vietnam
well I want to assure everyone that both
of those myths are entirely incorrect it
was simply his health simply his health
so wonder to me that his life is so
distorted I cannot literally understand
how a life could be so distorted for 37
years
this tall Texan was a federal official
started off at the age of 23 working for
congressman organized everybody else in
that job in Congress they became bad as
strong as the congressman and that's to
call the attention to President
Roosevelt only 23 years in Washington he
was a federal employee and then he
became at age 30
a congressman some 10 years later a
United States Senator minority leader
then at age 46 his colleagues United
States Senate elected him their Majority
Leader vice president United States
and then and in his mid-fifties he was
elected president but the largest
percentage of votes of any united
president to this day he recommended
more legislation in more subjects that
was passed by Congress and signed by
lyndon b johnson than any other
president to this date he was such a
doer can you imagine when I stand here
at 80 and I see what he accomplished in
64 years how I feel I've really not done
what I should have done maybe it could
have done but he was a doer and he did
not he did know how to get the job done
now I've read sometimes people didn't
like the way he got it done but the end
result it was finished in my opinion his
history is the most flawed the most
understated and the most misunderstood
of any past president by far no close
second my purpose is to cause try to
cause others to look instead of the
facts report and record the facts the
truth not to lies not to miss just the
facts
we're here we read how Vietnam was a war
of President Johnson the facts are
President Eisenhower recommended the
United States Senate they paid a seto
agreement the last of a series of
treaties had started with a NATO
agreement after world war ii the purpose
of all such treaties was to protect the
nation from a military invasion or
takeover of our foreign nation our an
alliance of nation now that's the Senate
did ratify that treaty and due to the
heart attacks of both President
Eisenhower and the majority leader
Lyndon Johnson Mike Mansfield was
requested and he did sign the treaty on
half of the government of the United
States of America today most of the
press
most of the educational faculty and many
if not most other political spokesmen
are quoting false information or how
listen carefully for the truth
oh I'll listen carefully for that as an
example when the past within the past
month I received this letter from
Elizabeth T Davis and on our senior at
the University of Michigan saying I am
writing I honor senior thesis on the
American Australian Alliance during the
Vietnam War see the sad thing about
their there was no alliance between
American and Australia except that that
truly included all the seto signatures
last year I spent a semester as a UNH
student London I don't remember you
doing this much traveling but last year
I spent a semester at a visit as a
visiting student at the University of
Melbourne where I took a class on
Australia's experienced during the
Vietnam War this class gave me a great
impression of what the war means to
Australia and the similarities and
differences between their experience and
the Americans in addition conversations
from Australian classmates about the
Vietnam and current Iraq Wars prompted
my interest in America's relations with
Australia the broad theme of my research
is looking at America's foreign policy
and how the u.s. one about making the
seven nation coalition during the
Vietnam War in particular I'm looking
how and whilst rally was so willing to
pursue to participate I am president
research he has Johnson's administration
went about creating coalition why our
coalition was necessary and what it
meant to both Americans and Australians
I feel this is an important topic since
Australia yet again was quick to join a
coalition in an American war I just got
back from researching
at the LBJ library but two weeks it was
a great experience and I got to look at
a lot of interest in the material yet I
came away from from my time feeling
frustrated since many important
questions could not be answered two
weeks two weeks here one term in
Australia so she says I think talking to
you either in person or over the phone
would be incredibly helpful for my
research well no I certainly do expect
to speak to this young lady
terribly I won't ask the question would
it be proper for some consideration be
given that from this depository of
information about Johnson other but more
about President Johnson to be made
available to talented and students at
the LBJ School or some other school to
study each of the President Johnson's
legislative successes by that I mean
legislation that was passed he signed
him if he sided he recommended it
there will be reams of information of
why recommended it be reams of
information know what it was supposed to
do the be hearings in the Congress and
whatnot
not only included legislation but the
things he was involved in such as
Vietnam and repairing outlined just
facts as to one have were and the
results friend such as the number of
citizens living under the poverty income
level when he became president was to
some twenty six percent of all Americans
now I now read whether he still used the
same standards that the president
johnson didn't used I do not know I now
read that's down to 12% why that would
be an important thing but could we get
these 12% out of the poverty level I
don't know it might help
but if you would do Vietnam which is the
thing that he seemed to be blamed for
which seems to blind most people as to
the most beautiful success story of any
president ever he could only say a
recommendation by President Eisenhower
was the seto agreement the United States
Senate agreed and ratified the South
East Asian Treaty Organization as did
six other nations
this was the Alliance of seven nations
all seven committed troops and resources
in answer to South Vietnam request for
military assistance to stop the invasion
into South Vietnam of the military of
North Vietnam President I put the first
US States military advisors into South
Vietnam and President Kennedy in a
speech I believe was two weeks before
his death stated there were some 26
thousand American troops in Vietnam and
whatever was necessary we the USA would
invest to stop the military invasion
into South Vietnam also the presidents
in his brother Bobby Kennedy to South
Vietnam to ensure and votes for that
nation saying publicly that the United
States of America will provide the
needed people and equipment to stop the
military invasion into South Vietnam
President Lyndon Johnson became
president he was told by our military
when they're attacked had been made
against our navy in international waters
for the North Vietnamese Navy books the
president insisted that Congress be told
and they'd be involved they had hearing
so the Congress did by 100% vote of the
United States House of Representatives
and 98 percent vote of the United States
Senate adopt the Tonkin Gulf Resolution
allowing our forces to be protected and
whatever military force was needed was
approved now these are the facts you
can't change the facts the president the
president's Eisenhower Kennedy Johnson
Nixon and Ford accepted these facts and
worked with them any different ideas -
these came months and years later as the
then worldwide communist ambition was
unleashed in this country
the Communists believed in the
denominator whether you or I did or not
present Eisner President Kennedy the US
military in South as far as I know in
1964 and 65 did the State Department and
all the presidential advisors so
believed in the domino theory remember
the military did not lose its will or
its purpose or the war in Vietnam or
Southeast Asian instead they're
developed to struggle and our nation
still goes on even in this election they
were we're happy they're about to
struggle for the minds of Americans the
struggle was financed at that time by
calmness governments and supported by
many mislead individuals and some very
good people as well the question was
will is there will an American to comply
with Osito tree at that time on this
planet there was 1 billion people
approximately that lived under democracy
there was 1 billion people lived on the
Commons rule and there was about 1
billion people decided which was going
to win so they know which way to hop
that why it was so important
should we have lost that small nation of
South Vietnam didn't sound much now but
then it's of great importance most then
believe those countries would first fall
would be last Cambodia Thailand
and eventually communism would have
taken over India and a vented Pacific
Rim yes it was difficult however ever
decision the president made was
recommended by 100% of by supported but
one instant of his advisors and by his
cabinet any contrary ideas came much
after the fact I listen now as people
say they had their doubts if so they
were on spoken and unknown a factual
record is so important the truth is
important I have not found a student
that has read or heard the truth what a
shame that Lyndon Baines Johnson who
insisted the truth with all of its bark
off has suffered the falsehood and evils
but uninformed and those that would do
this nation and his memory harm they
didn't remember who Lyndon Johnson was
he is in the hill country of Texas where
he had been taught it I thought we all
were back then that you word is your
bond a handshake is your agreement so
without fail the trees the contracts of
this nation were to be honored
it was our word and it was our duty it
was our sacred pledge it was right oh I
guess it's enough for Southeast Asia if
all of the facts were known and believed
remember most if not all the military
supported our nation's commitment and
they served with honor
they served with distinction and I did
not know there were any war criminals in
our military
Lyndon Johnson started as a teacher
after he was due doing all the history
that the books will remember he came
back to what he wanted to be was a
teacher he knew what being poor was you
can be poor in the pocket not hurt if
you have people who care about you and
if you have dreams and hopes yes
Lyndon Johnson learned from the past but
his vision was always for the future
always for the future he thought in
terms of potential how things could be
he knew that our potential rested with
our young he knew our technology was the
most advanced for the world but he was a
people president that new technology
alone could not solve social problems in
early manhood lyndon b johnson had a
burden that became a vision of hope for
every man woman and child this dedicated
young teacher became the champion of the
poor the sick the aged and the
disenfranchised his emotional strength
two of the three sit here tonight was a
companionship of his wife and his
daughters and their families he was a
leader who believed in the american
people knowing that they would call upon
their god-given inner strength and deal
with it in the proper way each of his
programs was put into place to enhance
the quality of life to him that anyone
would go to bed hungry sick or cold or
in need of an education in this great
land was reprehensible he believed in
her divine destiny for this nation not
that we should rule the world but serve
as an example and friend to the other
societies we do not live alone he said
we did not walk alone however if we must
we will stand alone for the cause of
right he said I will lead and I'll do
the best I can
but you must look within your own hearts
to the promises to the dreams that will
lead you best of all and for myself he
said I asked only in the words of an
ancient leader give me wisdom and
knowledge that I may go out and come in
before these people he adhere to the
principles that all men are created
equal
he signed into law hundreds of
legislative acts that wrote a record of
hope and opportunity for America and his
address before the joint session of
Congress March March 15 1965 after he
was elected to his own term he said my
first job after college was a teacher in
Cotulla Texas in a small
mexican-american school somehow you
never forget what poverty and hatred can
do when you see it scars in the hopeful
face of a young child I never thought
that in 1928 that I'd be standing here
in 1965 it never occurred to me in my
fondest dreams that I may have the
chance to help sons and daughters of
those students and to help people like
them all over this country but now I do
have the chance and I'll let you own a
secret I mean to use it and thank God he
did then then Johnson fulfilled that
promise to its fullest he exerted the
total leadership of his office to
advance their quality of all Americans
many criticized all but millions cheered
he stood on the cutting edge and made
sense out of nonsense today we enjoy the
minute benefits of the sacrifices he
made he history is cruel to many kind of
view
Lyndon Baines Johnson deserves to be
among the few we look back with
Thanksgiving for the love he had for us
and for the vision he crafted into
reality for all and so some of the
legacy of Lyndon Baines Johnson
chief of staff Lyndon Johnson and his
presidency is published by st. Martin's
Press on the web at st martin's done